so freunde da draußen an den geräten ich
hoffe ihr seid stolz auf euch da lässt
man euch mal fünf tage von der lockdown
leine und schon schlägt er über die
stränge nur wenige stunden nach unserer
freilassung musste uns die kanzlerin
direkt ermahnen mann mann mann mann mann
übrigens nicht ganz zu unrecht wenn ich
mir angucke was im deutschen parks und
fußgängerzonen schon wieder so abgeht
eine gewisse sorglosigkeit macht sich
breit
und dann hat die kanzlerin aber selber
ärger gekriegt und zwar für ein neues
substantiv dass die deutsche sprache
nicht wirklich gebraucht hätte öffnungs
diskussions orgien öffnungs diskussions
orgien öffnungs diskussions audi
eröffnungs diskussions audi öffnungs er
die eröffnungs dispositions orgien
diskussionen mit orgien die sind ja auch
gewissermaßen orgien teilnehmer das
stimmt hat aber mit corona gar nichts zu
tun
diskussion serbien ist es doch gut dass
endlich wieder mehr über wege aus der
krise gestritten wird auch über
grundrechte wenn man sich gleichzeitig
klar macht dass dem virus unsere rechte
herzlich egal sind und wozu bitte
wochenlange disziplin wenn wir direkt
wieder in massen die shoppingmeilen
fluten
wozu lockdown war eine klare sache jetzt
kommt der gefährliche mittelweg weiter
kontakt vermeidung aber offene läden und
leider sind ja nicht alle kunden so
vernünftig wie unser wirtschaftsminister
ich war heute in berlin unterwegs zu
einer von mir sehr geschätzten
konditorei die den gleichen gedanken
hatten noch andere und da dürfen immer
nur zwei zur gleichen zeit im laden sein
und haben dann darauf verzichtet und
dann haben wir den seitlichen frisch und
mit frischem obst über den tag gerettet
frisches obst ich mag mir das gar nicht
vorstellen meine damen und herren ja die
menschen wollen jetzt endlich wieder
shoppen sie wollen shoppen und zwar egal
was kein wunder vier fünf wochen zu
hause mit der eigenen familie
da liegen natürlich die nerven blank
hier mal ein kleines lager koller
best-of hustende frau getreten keinen
abstand gehalten supermarktkunden
prügeln sich oder man sperrt frau aus
angst vor corona virus
hat ein ja was ich muss eine show machen
da darf ich mich nicht von meiner frau
anstecken die groko sitzt in der mutter
aller zwickmühle wie verhindert man die
nächste infektionswelle und rettet
gleichzeitig die wirtschaft vor dem
endgültigen untergang
am dienstag haben sie das oktoberfest
gecancelt das oktoberfest
allein diese absage verursacht kein witz
einen schaden von 1,2 milliarden
eine unfassbare summe ich glaube eine
maß kostet mittlerweile auch 500 euro
und ab nächster woche haben wir dann
bundesweit masken pflicht masken pflicht
nachdem man uns wochenlang erzählt er
die bringen nichts macht jetzt plötzlich
jeder dürfe werbung für die teile nicht
bekommen hast dann zugeschickt in
unterschiedlicher form haben oder von
bestimmten firmen die einem das sehr
schön zu schicken auch mit der bayern
fahrer wie beispielsweise ich selber
bekommen jeden tag beispiele zugeschickt
was man alles machen kann mir werden
viele sachen zugeschickt zum beispiel
bayern maske ist mir schon zugeschickt
worden
und so geht es jeden tag ja wir haben es
kapiert eine gruppe schicken die masken
toll jetzt musste sie nur noch angst hin
dann bringt es auch was unsere politiker
treffen im moment historische
entscheidungen war immer noch absurd
misa datenlage wir wissen weder wie
viele menschen wirklich infiziert sind
noch kennen wir die ware sterberate und
seit dieser woche heißt es plötzlich
schon einfaches sprechen kann anstecken
sprechen
das zdf hat sofort reagiert
die zdf themenwoche presse deutschland
darauf haben alle gewartet das komplette
zdf sagt eine woche mal nichts im
heute-journal hält claus kleber jeden
abend 30 minuten die luft an
wir werden ihn nie vergessen maybrit
illner empfängt weiterhin gäste aber
keiner von ihnen darf auch nur ein wort
sagen
eine spezial folge traumschiff ganz ohne
die beschissenen dialoge 90 minuten nur
nebelhorn
so fällt gar nicht mehr auf was florian
silbereisen für ein wahnsinnig
schlechter schauspieler ist und auch die
heute show entfaltet ohne gelaber
endlich ihr volles potential die zdf
themenwoche fresse deutschland mit dem
zweiten schweigt man besser gott wäre
das schön freut
fakt ist wir können uns eben längst noch
nicht sicher fühlen
viele denken dass aber wir können uns
natürlich noch nicht sicher fühlen
andererseits der mensch braucht eine
perspektive er braucht licht am ende des
tunnels hoffnung also im prinzip das
exakte gegenteil von dem was karl
lauterbach jetzt in jedem interview
verbreitet kann durchaus sagen dass wir
das was wir jetzt sehen mit ein paar
minimalen veränderungen dass wir das
anderthalb jahre durchhalten müssen wir
müssen uns darauf einstellen dass es
möglicherweise bis 2022 geht er locker
war
was ich tragen sie im nächsten kalten
ich glaube das ist ja so den nächsten
karneval nicht erleben also ich werde
mir karl lauterbach doctor doom oder wie
ich ihn liebevoll das orakel von depri
unsere corona politik die deutsche
corona politik steckt voller
widersprüche
wenn wir uns weiter nur mit möglichst
wenig menschen treffen soll
was ich nachvollziehen kann warum machen
dann die schulen wieder auf eltern und
lehrer fragen völlig zu recht wie soll
das gehen mit dem hygiene konzept in
schulen mit nur zwei drei waschbecken
und ohne warmes wasser wie soll das
gehen
idee vielleicht bilden die eltern
einfach mal eine eimerkette vom
heimischen badezimmer bis in die schule
muss aber schnell gehen weil sonst wird
es kalt und weil ja viele privat zwei
waschbecken haben können die kinder noch
eins davon mit in die schule nehmen oder
eleganteste lösung die schüler nutzen
körpereigene warme flüssigkeit direkt
auch zum händewaschen
so hat corona keine chance ja klar
die kinder freuen sich wahrscheinlich
sogar wenn das mit dem elenden
homeschooling bald vorbei ist und sie
wieder von profis unterrichtet werden
dafür bleiben aber die kitas abgesehen
von notbetreuung wahrscheinlich noch
mindestens drei monate zu
drei monate soviel zum thema
vereinbarkeit von beruf und familie
zumal man ja die großeltern erst recht
nicht einspannen darf viele opas lesen
sich aus verzweiflung schon selber den
grüffelo vor die maus spazierte im wald
umher
der fuchs sah sie kommen und freute sich
sehr
hallo kleine maus so hin geht die reise
der familie zu hause ist ganz große
scheiße home office und kleine kinder
hat sich jetzt herausgestellt gehen doch
gar nicht so gut zusammen wer hätte das
gedacht
vielleicht liegt es daran dass frauen in
vielen familien weniger verdienen aber
tatsache ist die neue kita losigkeit
bleibt vor allem an ihnen hängen an den
frauen da könnte man sich wenigstens mal
bedanken und shaun smit sagen einfach
mal danke
was hier passiert leute es echt nicht in
ordnung
die kitas bleiben zu familien haben noch
monate aufeinander monat
und wer wartet es aus natürlich wieder
mal die frauen jahrzehntelang hieß es
die sollen karriere machen und jetzt nur
wegen corona fahren wir zurück geweihte
rollenbilder ich verstehe das ist eine
riesensauerei ist schon wieder 1950
kitas einfach zu lassen
wie soll das gehen meine frau zum
beispiel karin die hat jetzt ständig
videokonferenzen und macht gleichzeitig
den haushalt als sein
die kerze die fix und fertig so
tatsächlich weiter gehen und ihr geht es
ja noch gold
sie hat einen mann der auch zu hause
bleibt ja ich bin leider seit jahren
erwerbsunfähig wegen
glutenunverträglichkeit dass solche
corona helden leisten
das ist mit geld nicht zu bezahlen aber
vielleicht mit respekt deswegen
applaudiere ich jeden abend um 1745 für
meine eigene frau frauen hier macht das
echt super
was wir und alle sobald wir eine
millionen abonnenten haben liebe liebe
liebe fans ich würde mich so was schon
freuen wenn ihr ein abo damals er würde
den gern mag sowas und glücklich macht